ta peau contre map
la peau contre marc mollet protégés se
mettre un masque
ici ça met les mains donc le masque
c'est une barrière indispensable donc
les times il devrait verrouiller le
marché
les masques c'est moi qui les prends
c'est moi qui les paye est jeune et deux
parce que ça c'est une des commissaires
attend l'essm a fait l'état français
ahmadi
benji je vais te juste demandé juste un
truc va mettre une bouteille d'oxygène
et tu reprends en 3d malville mon run et
d'amour que j'aime qui nous rejoint à la
rentrée un tp je suis très heureux
puisque rami sera avec nous tous les
jeudis rené et rené je vais te dire
pourquoi j'ai envie que tu sois avec
nous parce qu'un tel personnage
2 je pense que tu es une vraie belle
personne et voilà et j'aime
voilà j'aime ce que tu véhicules et je
trouve que tu es voilà quelqu'un voilà
j'aime bien tu es un personnage était
quelqu'un qui est très attendrissant et
que j'aime énormément d'efforts mais si
on aura donc les bois boîte qui vont
arriver les chéris la chaîne voit là bas
m'a proposé de l'animé donc je suis très
heureux voilà et je sais qu'il ya plein
de gens qui lisent syrie située à nîmes
les boiboite essaie de les ouvrir plus
vite et il y aura bien sûr et je vous le
dis une boîte jusqu'à 250 euros
voilà donc y aura des serait très très
brillant je sais qu'un acquis danse bien
ici mais mathieu tu veux nous faire une
petite danse michael jackson a battu
michael hatch pas très bon qui sait bien
que ces propositions là allez vas-y
vas-y
il n'a pas perdu la main parce que vous
savez faire des imitations qu'il gardait
alors j'ai travaillé alors vas-y c'est
bon c'est bon c'est qu'ils répondraient
c'est qu'ils auraient trouvé il va tout
et julien clerc les salaires parce que
je crois que tu es mireille mathieu qui
nous regarde son voile et c'est bon
bonsoir petit terminateur pas fou non
gaulin la fortune les aie aie ça mais
l'europe en france pas à yves montand
mais tabac et ça ça quelqu'un de plus
face à de bons fous ton grand père on
sent poindre ouais bon jour c'est reggie
je suis content d'être là parce que la
télévision qu'on fait des ces différents
la télé confiné on essaie soit devant
l'ordinateur à la nuit et on peut
s'exprimer tranquillement oui j'ai tâté
les confiner et j'aime aussi le rappelle
n'a pas accepté le don libre à la
rené malleville est ce que tu es sur un
site de rencontres toi t'es sur teen
d'heure je sais même pas où et comment y
aller à fond des mers tu sais comment
les chefs mais comme ça mais je n'ai
jamais regardé aucune de cul je sais pas
ce que c'est de regarder nord horvath a
raison je n'ai jamais et je n'ai jamais
eu besoin de ses comptables n'ont pas
lieu d'être a bien fait bah oui voilà et
aux normes toit de satyam est vraiment
atteinte a connu à tout discours main
d'oeuvre dans ta vie renaît non mais je
recevrai la côte et toi jean luc
reichmann
il s'est exprimé depuis son lieu de
confinement dans une petite vidéo
adressé aux téléspectateurs à la fin des
élections
jean michel à rennes vers celle d'un
instant on parlera de jean luc lahaye
qui ne respectent pas le confinement
pour lui le continent ne veut rien dire
il dit même que c'est une supercherie et
avoue même je vous le dit rouler vite
dans les rues de paris avec sa moto
alors est-ce que vous à la maison vous
êtes choqué par ses propos de jean luc
lahaye honnêtement on parle de qui on
parle de jean lucas et moi j'ai revu ce
qu'il a dit à gauche à droite vince
gable ou cheryl a eu en plateau j'ai eu
en plateau il dit que des bêtises depuis
30 ans voilà c'est ça fait 2 ferez vous
c'est pas un mot s'est passé c'est un
gentil garçon c'est un provocateur
hilarant 24 euros non mais attendez
attendez
jean luc lahaye donner de noms je veux
je vous dis est ce que vous êtes choqués
que jean-luc a dit ça non et oui jean
luc est avec nous merci jean luc lahaye
d'être avec no mercy jean-luc merci
merci valérie était assez remonté hier
contre jean-luc qui est vraiment en plus
voilà quel courage de venir ici ce soir
pour nous faire nous re re préciser son
propos qu'est ce que tu as dit un témoin
je suis absolument ravi de vous entendre
dire qu'il s'agit avec l'aed c'est
effectivement vos propos hier mois la
tête que je les ai reçus et c'était pas
des on dit et ce que vous disiez passe
caméra pour moi je les écris tel quel je
vous ai entendu dire effectivement que
ça ne concernait que vous savez de
conséquence ni personne d'autre
moi ça m'a fait bondir de mon siège bien
évidemment maintenant je suis à l'arrêt
0 oui j'ai menti
maintenant je suis extrêmement heureuse
de s'étendre mais vous restez les gestes
barrières que vous respectez les
consignes de confinement
merci beaucoup c'est vrai que hocine
concerne j'assume mes actes
quand je vais pas acheter des conneries
je vais assumer j'ai toujours assumé
mais là c'est une situation n'est
vraiment terrible comme disait rené où
il ya des chaque jour des familles qui
sont dans le deuil et je le déplore
c'est dramatique c'est j'ai ma soeur qui
est infirmière anesthésiste et chaque
jour elle me fait pas de ce qu'elle a vu
des personnes qu'elle a vu dans la peine
de sept amis qui viennent on leur
apprend que c'est fini c'est terrible
donc je profite vraiment à faire
attention je suis moi même extrêmement
prudent et cyril je te disais mon mode
de vie
gérard mode de vie extrêmement simple
c'est pas pour autant que je vais me
lâcher dans les rues ces jeunes dansent
sur les places de mon enfant je ne
m'arrête pas je je je suis extrêmement
prudent je prends cela très au sérieux
franchement j'ai toujours trouvé ça
d'histoire et ça mignon au regard des
mâts castaldi débours
il est magnifique bravo castard pedrola
il et il est fort agréable dit comme ça
voilà baykal a aimé mais il a le sens du
spectacle
la rolls alors vous êtes excusé moi vous
êtes vous est ce qu'on appelle un enfant
de la balle
la boisson que c'est de perdre de père
en fils brice et ce à travers sa
génération
non mais c'est incroyable il a le sens
du spectacle c'est incroyable c'est
super on va trouver des cons qu'ils vont
dire à offrir une citation à les
milliardaires
donc elle peut donner 6 millions et ben
non excusez-moi il faut saluer les
gestes de tous ceux qui donnent que soit
5 euros 10 euros 1000 euros 6 millions
d'euros ça me rend dingue ces discours
là haut penja
franchement c'est une ronde web beyoncé
elle a beaucoup d'argent mais elle fait
un chèque de sima mon pote
alema faut arrêter à mécénat énorme et
100 millions d'euros donc moi je trouve
ça pas bien alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
on donne pas on vous reproche de pas
donner
vous donnait on vous reproche d'avoir
dit que vous avez donnée au lâcher nous
est offert au fait où on fait des choses
et en plus il ya des tas de gens qui
donne moi j'ai appris ça il ya de ça
vous il ya plein de gens qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de gens qui donnent aux
hôpitaux qui était arrêtée de tomber
tout suspect suspicieux voilà on peut
faire des choses normalement sans qu'on
ait eu on le fasse par intérêt arrêter
avec ça c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable et un jour qu'est ce qui
va se passer
eh ben les gens ils donneront plus ils
vont se barrer on leur dira oui au parti
bah oui son parti ou leur avait craché
dessus et ben voila moi ça m'énerve
bah voilà le forcené a poussé son il
fonctionnait la wii